[Music]
we're still learning about covert 19.
we know it came from an animal but does
that mean they also need the jab
[Music]
our furry friends can become carriers of
the disease and in rare instances turn
into a risk for owners
[Music]
safari parks zoos and shelters have
started inoculating apes
lions and wolves to protect us and the
animals
the experimental vaccines are
specifically made for them
conservationists say we brought this on
ourselves by our disrespect of nature
forcing animals ever closer to humans
[Music]
a team of experts met for the first time
this week to help develop a global plan
to stop the spread of diseases from
animals to humans
meantime russia has developed the first
coronavirus vaccine for animals
releasing an initial batch of 17
000 doses researchers in finland and the
u.s are working on similar jobs
this cat is a pioneer albeit an
unwilling one
kesha the cat is one of the first
recipients of the first ever
19 vaccine for animals
his owners daniel and elvira say they
signed up for the vaccination
just to be on the safe side
our cat goes outside a lot sometimes he
doesn't even come home at night because
he's doing his own thing but he lives
with us
so we're always concerned he could bring
an infection home with him
we plan to start a family and heard that
kovit could be dangerous for pregnant
women
so it's better to be safe it doesn't
hurt the cat
the vaccine will provide these cats with
immunity from the coronavirus for at
least
six months according to the doctors here
animals can show respiratory symptoms of
the disease
problems breathing a cough or a loss of
their sense of smell
essentially the symptoms are the same as
they are for people just in a much much
lighter form
but it's not the symptoms themselves
that are a concern here
the world health organization has warned
that animals including minks
could become carriers for the
coronavirus and even pass it back to
people
last year 17 million minks were culled
in denmark
after some of them caught covet 19.
the russian-made vaccine called carnivak
cove
could prevent that according to
developers the country's veterinary and
agricultural watchdog
rosseljosnadzor began trials on rabbits
dogs cats foxes and other animals in
october
now they say the jab is ready for mass
production
the vaccine was developed as a
preventative measure something aimed at
the future
in case there are negative situations
like the development of a mutation that
can be passed between different types of
animals
we shouldn't forget that any measures
for disease prevention for animals
prevent people getting sick as well
because around 70 percent of human
diseases come from animals
the vaccines developers say there has
already been demand for the job from
businesses in several european countries
including in germany rosel josnadzor
recommends the vaccine for animals kept
in close contact
including at fur farms and zoos they say
that for now
pets like these cats are very unlikely
to become a risk to their owners
thomas mettenlighter is president of the
friedrich loffler institute
aren't we taking things a little too far
tomorrow's vaccinating animals or
is that the strategy that we may need to
beat this pandemic
i think we have to define what animals
we actually mean
if we talk about pets for example i mean
pets get infected from their infected
owners but there is no single documented
case
that pets actually transfer the virus
back to humans
the situation is different for fur
producing animals like for example mink
there the infection in ming farms
originates from humans but then
mink replicate the virus to a large
extent and then are able indeed to
re-infect
humans so there are documented cases in
that aspect
when it comes to pets how much of this
is a money maker would you say and how
much
is essential
in terms of pets i i think i mean the
the prime
procedure not to infect them is to keep
a distance if you are infected yourself
so if you are in isolation then keep
away from your pets as much as possible
i don't think there is an indication for
a vaccination of of pets
in terms of fur producing animals the
situation is a little different
there we have the possibility that the
virus replicates
growth in the in these farms to a very
large extent
and this can suffice to then re-infect
humans so vaccination in this particular
setting
might be one of the options of course
there are others and
the preferred option for me at least
would be vaccinate humans in the first
place
so that humans are not no longer posing
a danger for animals
whether they are pets or whether they
are for producing animals
in fur producing animals we have seen a
situation that the virus
because it it replicates it multiplies
so much that variance gets selected
and some of these variants could at
least theoretically indeed pose a
problem
so there might also be an indication for
vaccinating this kind of animals to
avoid
this the appearance of these variants
and a good point there we should think
about the animals as well of course
a lot of farm animals they were already
pumped with antibiotics to prevent the
spread of diseases
and that's had all sorts of adverse
effects on our health too
i mean in the situation with farm
animals uh and
and kovit 19 um there is no reason for
concern as far as we can see
um livestock and poultry are to a large
extent or absolutely resistant
towards this virus at least this is true
for for pigs and it's
it's true for chicken and ducks and and
turkeys
uh cattle show a very very limited
susceptibility which also doesn't pose a
problem
at the moment so i mean in terms of that
kind of animal i think we are on the
safe side
thomas intervening in nature in general
got us into this mess in the first place
couldn't more intervention increase risk
i mean viruses
are part of nature and the the function
of ecosystems
i mean it's true viruses are part of
nature and humans are part of the animal
kingdom
in a shared environment so basically i
mean this is what biology is all about
but on the other hand i mean there have
been interventions in
in wildlife populations that were
beneficial
if you have a defined population and a
defined pathogen
a defined infectious agent this could
work and
examples are for example rabies
fox-mediated rabies
which has been eradicated in central
europe by bait immunization of foxes
a classical swine fever has been
eradicated from wild boar also in
central europe by bait immunization
and rinderpest has been eradicated
globally
but i mean these are special situations
and i fully agree i don't think that
vaccinating
wildlife populations or any intervention
in wildlife populations
um gives and gives a better situation
um i think i mean it's more the change
of human habits uh
which is which is required to avoid
these spillover events
but even these spillover events that
happen probably regularly
are also part of nature well you
mentioned we should all get the jab a
lot of us
are is there some other way we can
change our behavior to lower
this risk
i mean it's difficult to define clearly
the interface between wildlife and
humans or or livestock and humans
but definitely lowering risky contacts
whatever they may be is definitely one
of the major measures of
a decrease in in risk in general this
will also decrease
decrease the risk in these spillovers
that is has to do with direct contact
with animals it has to do with
going into wildlife habitats too
strongly
interfering with wildlife populations
interfering with biodiversity
so this is a whole range of of measures
that actually need to be taken into
account
thomas madden leiter president of the
friedreich lovely institute thank you
very much for being on the show today
you're very welcome as far as vaccines
for humans go here's a good question for
derek williams our science correspondent
can you mix doses of different vaccines
circumstances have really kind of forced
opinions to shift
some on this issue um to give you an
idea
of how complex it's become let's look at
the situation
here in germany um until a few weeks ago
mixing and matching vaccines was pretty
forboden here because the only safety
and
efficacy data that we had came from
trials involving two dose regimens
of the same vaccines and because
diverging from that
would mean sailing into kind of
uncharted waters
then very rare cases of serious blood
clotting events thought to be caused by
the astrazeneca vaccine
began popping up in younger people and
and that
prompted authorities here to re-evaluate
recommendations
for people under 60 who had already
received
a first dose of astrazeneca and then
for the second administered dose the
authorities now
recommend using a messenger rna vaccine
like the one from
pfizer biontech a brand new spanish
study
now indicates that that regimen is both
safe
and and maybe even a lot more effective
but
in the weeks before those results came
in the authorities had to make a choice
and they decided that one risk
which in younger people is very rarely
developing a serious blood clot
after a second dose of astrazeneca that
that
outweighed the risk of mixing and
matching vaccines
in general most experts seem to think
that receiving a follow-up dose
that's different from your first dose
shouldn't really pose
major problems still health authorities
are
are pretty conservative and they'll want
really a lot of solid proof
a recent british study looking into some
combinations
indicated that that mixing and matching
while
apparently safe also sometimes provokes
more side effects
than two doses of the same vaccine
other studies looking at a range of
different combinations
are ongoing and we and we should know a
lot more
by this summer
[Music]
derek williams there i'm ben fazoulen
thanks for watching stay safe
and see you again soon
[Music]